>> Chris: KRISTIN FISHER
REPORTING FROM THE WHITE HOUSE,
THANK YOU.
AND JOINING US NOW, DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI, THE GOVERNMENT’S TOP
OFFICIAL ON INFECTIOUS DISEASES
AND WELCOME BACK TO
"FOX NEWS SUNDAY."
I WANTED TO START WITH THOSE
VIDEOS THAT KRISTIN FISHER JUST
SHOWED OF THOSE THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE AT AIRPORTS OVERNIGHT
RUSHING TO BEAT THE TRAVEL BAN
WAITING ON LINE FOR HOURS WHEN
YOU CAN THEM HERE IN CLOSE
PROXIMITY ONE ASSUMES COMING
BACK FROM EUROPE, SOME OF THEM
HAVE THE CORONAVIRUS AND AS AN
INFECTIOUS DISEASE DOCTOR, ARE
YOU TROUBLED SEEING THIS?
>> WE WOULD LIKE TO NOT SEE
CROWDS LIKE THAT.
WHAT PEOPLE NEED TO UNDERSTAND
IS IF YOU’RE AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN, YOU CAN GET BACK.
YOU DON’T NEED TO RUSH BACK, YOU
WILL BE ABLE TO GET BACK BUT
IT’S UNDERSTANDABLE HOW WHEN
PEOPLE SEE THE TRAVEL BAN, THEY
IMMEDIATELY WANT TO HUNKER AND
GET HOME, HOPEFULLY WE DON’T
HAVE MORE OF THAT BUT I THINK WE
PROBABLY UNFORTUNATELY WILL SEE
THAT.
>> Chris: IS NOT A PROBLEM IN
TERMS OF THE SPREAD OF THE
DISEASE?
>> THAT’S THE THING WE’VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THAT WE REALLY
WANT TO IMPLEMENT IS TO HAVE
THAT KIND OF SOCIAL SEPARATION,
THAT IS COUNTER DEMANDING THAT
AND HOPEFULLY PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
YOU DON’T HAVE TO RUSH BACK.
>> Chris: TO WHAT DEGREE IS IT
ON THE AIRPORTS TO PREVENT THAT
AND NOT HAVE THOSE BIG CROWDS OF
PEOPLE WAITING FOR HOURS?
>> I DON’T KNOW WHAT THE
AIRPORTS CAN DO ABOUT THAT TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO TELL THEM
THAT IF YOU ARE AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN, YOU WILL BE ABLE TO GET
BACK, IT’S NOT GOING TO BE A
PROBLEM.
>> Chris: YOU TESTIFIED BEFORE
CONGRESS THIS WEEK AND YOU MADE
WHAT MOST PEOPLE WOULD CONSIDER
SOME PRETTY CHILLING COMMENTS.
HERE THEY ARE.
>> BOTTOM LINE, IT’S GOING TO
GET WORSE.
THE FLU HAS A MORTALITY OF 0.1%.
THIS HAS A MORTALITY OF TEN
TIMES THAT.
>> Chris: WHAT IS DIFFERENT
ABOUT THIS VIRUS?
WHAT IS DIFFERENT AND HOW
CONTAGIOUS IT IS AND HOW LETHAL
IT IS?
>> I WOULD SAY THREE THINGS, ONE
IS IT’S BRAND-NEW SO WE DON’T
HAVE ANY PRIOR EXPERIENCE ABOUT
WHAT IT’S GOING TO DO AND WHAT
ITS DYNAMICS ARE GOING TO BE.
NUMBER TWO, IT SPREADS VERY
EASILY.
THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
ISN’T LIKE SOME OF THE OTHER
OUTBREAKS THAT WE HAD THAT JUST
DIDN’T ADAPT ITSELF TO SPREAD
AMONG HUMANS AND NUMBER THREE,
IT’S VERY SERIOUS IN THE SENSE
OF MORBIDITY AND MORTALITY
PARTICULARLY AMONG AND VERY
HEAVILY WEIGHTED TOWARDS
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE.
THE ELDERLY AND THOSE WITH
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS.
>> Chris: IN TERMS OF
CONTAGIOUSNESS AND LETHALITY,
WORSE THAN THE FLU?
>> IT JUST IS AND WE HAVE TO
FACE THAT FACT, WE HAVE TO BE
REALISTIC AND I SAID THAT AT THE
HEARING AND THAT THINGS ARE
GOING TO GET WORSE BEFORE THEY
GET BETTER, BUT THE KINDS OF
THINGS WE ARE DOING NOW WILL
HOPEFULLY MITIGATE THAT.
I SHOWED THAT CURVE.
>> Chris: WE ARE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THAT.
>> THAT’S IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE
THINK THAT RIGHT NOW EVERYTHING
IS GOING TO BE OKAY IF YOU DON’T
DO ANYTHING, THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
INCORRECT.
WE’VE GOT TO REALLY ALWAYS BE
AHEAD OF THE CURVE.
I SAY NOW IN A WAY THAT PEOPLE
CAN UNDERSTAND, I’D LIKE TO BE
THE FACT THAT WE ARE CRITICIZED
FOR BEING OVERREACTIVE.
WHEN YOU ARE DEALING WITH A
VIRUS OUTBREAK, YOU’RE ALWAYS
BEHIND WHERE YOU THINK YOU ARE.
SO THEREFORE, YOU’VE GOT TO JUMP
AHEAD AND STAY AHEAD OF THE
CURVE.
>> Chris: I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT THIS.
ON FRIDAY, BOTH YOU AND THE
PRESIDENT AT ONE POINT MENTIONED
EIGHT WEEKS.
YOU WEREN’T SAYING IT’S ALL
GOING TO BE OVER IN EIGHT WEEKS,
BUT ARE YOU SUGGESTING THAT IF
WE DO EVERYTHING RIGHT, THAT WE
COULD BE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE CURVE IN EIGHT WEEKS?
>> FIRST OF ALL, WE HAVE TO SAY
THAT PEOPLE DON’T MISUNDERSTAND,
WE ARE NOT SURE WHAT THE
DURATION IS GOING TO BE.
NUMBER TWO, IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENED IN CHINA WHERE THEY HAD
THAT PEAK AND THEN ONLY 11 NEW
CASES IN CHINA, THEY DOMINATED
THE NEW CASES JUST A FEW MONTHS
AGO SO IT STARTED OFF IN CHINA,
TWO OR THREE MONTHS AGO, THEY
STARTED COMING DOWN WITHIN A TWO
MONTH PERIOD.
SO IF YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
REFLECTING WHAT WENT ON THERE,
IT’S GOING TO BE ABOUT THAT TIME
THAT WE HOPEFULLY IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF MONTHS ARE GOING TO
SEE THE DIRECTION IT’S GOING TO
GO.
HOPEFULLY WHAT WE ARE DOING IN
THE VERY AGGRESSIVE WAY OF
CONTAINMENT AND MITIGATION WILL
BE ABLE TO NOT ONLY FLATTEN IT
IN THE SENSE OF NOT AS MANY
CASES BUT ALSO DIMINISH THE
DURATION.
>> Chris: PRESIDENT TRUMP
ANNOUNCED A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP ON FRIDAY AND MADE
IT SOUND LIKE SERIOUS TESTING
AROUND THE COUNTRY THAT WE WILL
BE SEEING SOON.
FIRST, THERE WAS THIS.
>> I WANT TO THINK OF GOOGLE,
GOOGLE IS HELPING TO DEVELOP A
WEB SITE THAT IS GOING TO BE
VERY QUICKLY DONE UNLIKE
WEB SITES OF THE PAST.
>> Chris: GOOGLE SISTER
COMPANY VERILY PUT OUT A
STATEMENT LATER THAT SAID THIS
TEST, WHICH ACCORDING TO OTHER
OFFICIALS FIRST OF ALL WILL LET
YOU CHECK WHETHER YOUR SYMPTOMS
INDICATE YOU HAVE IT AND IF YOU
DO SEEM TO HAVE IT, WILL TELL
YOU WHERE YOU CAN GET TESTING.
IN FACT, IS JUST STARTING AND IS
JUST AN PILOT PROGRAM FOR THE
BAY AREA AND IT’S GOING TO TAKE
OVER TIME THEY SAID FOR IT TO BE
APPLIED NATIONALLY AND WHILE THE
PRESIDENT MADE IT SOUND LIKE
MASS TESTING IS GOING TO START
VERY SOON, THERE WERE A LOT OF
EXPERTS WHO SAY THAT WHETHER IT
IS STAFFING, PUBLIC HEALTH
STAFFING OR THE PRODUCTS OR THE
CHEMICALS NEEDED FOR MASS
TESTING THAT WE ARE WAY BEHIND
THE CURVE ON THAT SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS HOW SOON CAN PEOPLE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY EXPECT MASS
DRIVE THROUGH TESTING?
>> THEY WERE TWO ISSUES HERE.
A WEB SITE AND WHEN IT’S GOING
TO BE FULLY OPEN VERSUS THE
AVAILABILITY OF TESTING.
THEY REALLY ARE SOMEWHAT
SEPARATE.
SO PUT ASIDE THE WEB SITE AND
HOW IT’S GOING TO BE FULLY
OPERATIONAL, THE CEOs OF THE
COMPANY’S THAT WE HAD AT THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT THE PRESIDENT
MET WITH, IT’S VERY CLEAR THAT
WHEN I SPECIFICALLY ASK THEM
WHEN CAN WE GET STARTED TO START
DOING THIS WHERE YOU CAN REALLY
HAVE AVAILABILITY IN A MUCH
EASIER WAY IMPLEMENTING, NOT
JUST SAYING THAT IT’S OUT THERE,
THEY ARE TELLING US THAT WE’LL
BE STARTING UP WITHIN THE NEXT
WEEK OR SO THAT’S GOING TO GO
UP.
IN THE REALITY, THEY WERE GOING
TO BE PEOPLE A WEEK FROM NOW WHO
ARE GOING TO SAY I TRIED TO GET
A TEST AND I COULDN’T GET IT BUT
THE TOTALITY OF THE PICTURE IS
GOING TO BE INFINITELY BETTER
THAN IT WAS A FEW WEEKS AGO.
>> Chris: I WANT TO TALK TO
YOU ABOUT A FEW WEEKS AGO
BECAUSE THEY ARE CONTINUING
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHY OTHER
COUNTRIES ARE TESTING THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE A DAY AND SO FAR, THE
CDC SAYS THAT EIGHT AND STATE
LABS TOTAL, THE WHOLE CRISIS
HAVE TESTED 13,000 PEOPLE.
HERE’S HOW YOU WHEN THE
PRESIDENT ANSWERED QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE TESTING LAG THIS WEEK.
>> THE IDEA OF ANYBODY GETTING
IT EASILY THE WAY PEOPLE IN
OTHER COUNTRIES ARE DOING IT, WE
ARE NOT SET UP FOR THAT.
DO I THINK WE SHOULD BE?
YES, BUT WE ARE NOT.
>> I DON’T TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
AT ALL BECAUSE WE WERE GIVEN A
SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES AND WE WERE
GIVEN RULES, REGULATIONS, AND
SPECIFICATIONS FROM A DIFFERENT
TIME.
>> Chris: THE PRESIDENT SAID
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION SET UP
RULES AND REGULATIONS THAT MADE
IT IMPOSSIBLE TO DO TESTING.
HE WERE IN THE SAME POSITION
UNDER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
IS THAT TRUE?
IS THAT WHAT STOPPED AT?
>> TO BE HONEST WITH YOU, I’M
NOT SURE WHAT REGULATIONS AND
WHAT THEY’RE TALKING ABOUT.
I REALLY MEAN THAT.
I’M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IT
IS THAT THESE THINGS WERE IN
PLACE THAT WERE ABLE TO OR
INHIBITING BUT ONE THING THAT I
DO KNOW NOW IS THAT THE ABILITY
TO GET A TEST HAD SOME
REGULATORY AND OTHER
RESTRICTIONS ON IT BUT THE FDA
NOW HAS JUST GOTTEN RID OF.
>> Chris: THEY COULD HAVE DONE
THAT DAY ONE.
>> THEY COULD HAVE BUT THAT
PROBLEM IS THEY DIDN’T SO
INSTEAD OF LOOKING BACK, LOOKING
AT WHERE IT GOING.
>> Chris: YOU TALK ABOUT
SLOWING THE VIRUS DOWN, I’VE
GOTTEN VERY USED TO THIS NOW,
YOU COULD EITHER HAVE A BUMP
LIKE THIS OF CASES OR YOU
COULDN’T MAKE IT THE SAME TOTAL
CASES BUT IT’S A MUCH MORE
GRADUAL AND SLOWER AND LONGER
CURVE.
I WANT TO PUT UP SOME NUMBERS.
WE HAVE IN THIS COUNTRY ABOUT
950,000 HOSPITAL BEDS AND ABOUT
45,000 BEDS IN INTENSIVE CARE
UNITS.
HOW WORRIED ARE YOU THAT THIS
VIRUS IS GOING TO OVERWHELM
HOSPITALS, NOT JUST BEDS, BUT
VENTILATORS.
WE ONLY HAVE 160,000 VENTILATORS
AND COULD WE BE IN A SITUATION
WHERE YOU HAVE TO RATION WHO
GETS THE BED, WHO GETS THE
VENTILATOR?
>> LET ME PUT IT IN A WAY SO
THAT IT DOESN’T GET TAKEN OUT OF
CONTEXT.
WHEN PEOPLE TALK ABOUT MODELING
WHERE OUTBREAKS ARE GOING, IT’S
ONLY AS GOOD AS THE ASSUMPTIONS
YOU PUT INTO THE MODEL AND WHAT
THEY DO, THEY HAVE A WORSE CASE
SCENARIO, A BEST-CASE SCENARIO,
AND LIKELY WHERE IT’S GOING TO
BE.
WE HAVE A WORSE CASE SCENARIO,
WE’VE GOT TO ADMIT IT.
WE COULD BE OVERWHELMED.
ARE WE GOING TO HAVE A WORSE
CASE SCENARIO?
I DON’T THINK SO, I HOPE NOT.
WHAT ARE WE DOING TO NOT HAVE
THAT WORST-CASE SCENARIO?
THAT’S WHEN YOU GET INTO THE
THINGS THAT WE ARE DOING.
WE ARE PREVENTING INFECTIONS
FROM GOING IN WITH SOME RATHER
STRINGENT TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS
AND WE ARE DOING CONTAINED
MITIGATION FROM WITHIN SO AT A
WORST-CASE SCENARIO, ANYWHERE IN
THE WORLD NO MATTER WHAT COUNTRY
YOU ARE, YOU WILL BE PREPARED.
OUR JOB IS TO NOT LET THAT
WORST-CASE SCENARIO HAPPEN.
>> Chris: FINAL QUESTION,
THREE COUNTRIES NOW IN EUROPE,
ITALY, SPAIN, AND FRANCE ARE
BASICALLY IN TOTAL LOCKDOWN.
PEOPLE NOT ALLOWED OUT IN ITALY.
I THINK ONLY PHARMACIES AND
GROCERY STORES ARE OPEN.
YOU SEE PEOPLE ON THE BALCONIES
SINGING SONGS AND BANGING POTS,
COULD THAT HAPPEN HERE EITHER
NATIONALLY OR IN SOME REGIONS
AND WHAT ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY
THAT WE MIGHT HAVE TO HAVE
TRAVEL BAN’S INSIDE THE COUNTRY?
>> A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS THERE
SO LET ME TAKE ONE AT A TIME.
THE IDEA OF WHAT’S GOING IN
EUROPE IS THEY HAVE -- THEY GOT
INTO THAT ESCALATION PHASE SO
WHAT THEY ARE DOING NOW IS
PLAYING CATCH UP.
WE FEEL THAT WITH RATHER
STRINGENT MITIGATION AND
CONTAINMENT WITHOUT NECESSARILY
COMPLETE LOCKDOWN, WE’D BE ABLE
TO PREVENT OURSELVES FROM
GETTING TO WHERE UNFORTUNATELY
ITALY IS NOW.
WITH REGARD TO DOMESTIC TRAVEL
BANDS, WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT IT
AND CONSIDER EVERYTHING BUT I
CAN TELL YOU THAT IS NOT BEING
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERED, DOING
TRAVEL BANDS.
WOULD IT SOMETIME?
WE ALWAYS LEAVE AN OPEN MIND.
>> Chris: THANK YOU, THANKS
FOR COMING IN, AN AWFUL LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE RELYING ON WHAT YOU
HAVE TO SAY AND OF COURSE WE